for 50 years we've been stuck with the
same old lightsaber look and it's got me
thinking what we could just break out of
that little box and make it look as cool
as we wanted but we're going to do just
that in this video with the combination
of realistic choreography cutting edge
camera tech and brand new visual effects
techniques we're going to reinvent the
lightsaber
the lightsaber a classic weapon elegant
weapon for the more civilized days
the concept of an energy sword has
existed beyond just a lightsaber it's
not something that's specific just to
star wars and if you look at star wars i
feel like there's been a lot of
stagnation in the idea of an energy
sword
if you look at what a fight scene is
supposed to mean you know two human
beings dueling to the death it's intense
emotions it should be the height of
storytelling but oftentimes lightsabers
end up being showy flashy acrobatic
displays hollywood has a bit of an issue
here they get scared of reinventing
things and so we've taken it upon
ourselves to see if we can reinvent the
lightsaber through reapproaching
choreography to changing how we would
approach visual effects i think we can
make an energy sword that feels more
visceral more real and perhaps more
dramatic than the classic lightsaber
from star wars we're going to shoot a
little cinematic short film about a
school that teaches sword dueling we
want you to feel the life and death
drama of this sword fight which means
shooting things smooth and cinematically
no handheld shaky footage here however
we don't have expensive equipment or a
big crew so we're gonna be using the new
ronin 4d from dji to get this done
so can we improve on lightsaber duels
from star wars well follow along with us
here and you'll see a finished short
film at the end of this piece and you
can be the judge
so let's start with probably the most
important thing the choreography we've
reached out to our good friend luke
lafontaine who is a sword expert you
might remember on a react episode a long
time ago the first time luke joined us
he went on a little rant about
lightsaber fights do you ever notice
when these guys all swing really hard
they make these power swings the blades
made out of light it doesn't weigh
anything why would you have to swing it
hard
and so we want to put that into action
we want to actually go out there and
make what we think a lightsaber fight
should actually look like
i had this thing that was plasma that
was burning in a million degrees and i
touched you with it how would you really
fight with it so even though we're in a
fantasy based world
i want dramatic intention and reality
and i want the audience to be scared and
i'm not scared if this guy does a triple
backflip and a butterfly twist in the
middle of this deadly sword fight where
it's like well while you're in the air
i'm just gonna cut you in half how's
that
the beginning of this fight is tentative
movement
nobody really wants to commit the minute
you cross blades
it's literally like well you can kill me
i can kill you so
let me temper this with a little bit of
ocean i've got to pay attention to my
technique and get focused now because
this isn't a fist fight just fight what
are you gonna do you don't punch me in
the face
i get a black eye you break my nose who
cares sword fight
all you gotta do is flinch the wrong way
and i've opened up your forearm i've
taken your hand off i mean a lot of the
classic star wars movies how many people
have lost their hand
these are energy based weapons all i'm
trying to do is go
move your blade that much
i'm going to cut your forearm and take
your hand off i don't have to do more
than that with a lightsaber bang whack
i've cut your hand off now i cut you
down through the body i win you lose
typically the way swordfights are done
in hollywood it would look like this
he can very slowly show you how many
different times he can hit me while i'm
doing that there it is here it is
both my arms have been cut off more than
once i'm also noticing there's some
footwork in that
as you push in he's dropping back and
keeping his range so you're very much
paying attention to
when you're in the the kill zone or it's
not in the kill zone if you ask me
what's the most important thing in sword
fighting distancing
if you as a swordsman could utterly
master distancing
you'd never get cut the choreography has
been nailed down and now we need to make
the camera part of the choreography so
i'm going to be using this camera trying
to figure out camera moves i can
accentuate this make it look cool get
you involved dramatically but also
clearly show the fight
it's my belief that a camera is the
third participant in a duel between two
people on screen because you can always
throw the camera on a tripod and throw
it in the background but it's boring you
want to get in there you want to show
the audience something you want to say
something with your cinematography
so after seeing all that on camera and
working out some more character beats
into the choreography and getting these
cool sweeping shots i am really excited
to shoot this piece so the first time in
my life i got to spend a thousand
dollars in lightsabers
so i had to get the brightest heaviest
duty lightsabers they had and i had to
get two of each
so back in the day when they did
lightsabers they're just basically
painting over the film frame the
lightsaber itself was it was just stick
it didn't shoot any light into the scene
but now in modern times we'd have these
things called leds which didn't exist
back in the 70s and so now we can make
lightsabers that actually emit light and
our material science has gotten advanced
enough where the blades don't break as
easily who wants to whack a lightsaber
that's a dream come true
this is dope it's really cool it seems
like there's enough durability in these
things okay
these things are sick yeah they are they
really are cool
what up son what up son here we are
again what are you doing here oh you
know i'm just here to help facilitate
you know you stand in the background
help people you know hurt watching these
guys fight you know watching the skill
levels really good yeah it'll be a good
time it's a cool location
we've already worked out the shot list
niko's got in his head he knows what
he's doing i just got to make sure
nobody actually lops anybody in the eye
or forgets choreography
i think this is
the first narrative shot on this camera
action
[Music]
it's been taxing just the specificity of
everything is really tricky luke has
very high standards but it's good and
the choreography makes sense so in that
sense it's not hard at all it all flows
naturally it's just like really dialing
it in that's that's tricky
so there's like a million things that
are cool about this camera but this
little guy which lets me do dolly shots
on my feet is like one of the coolest
parts so this shot i'm going to be nice
and low to the ground
i'm going to skim along it like this you
notice how the head stays even while i'm
bobbling with my feet that literally
there's actually a sonar i believe on
the bottom that measures the distance
it's basically all the same tech from
their drones but packed into a camera
having that fourth axis stabilization is
pretty insane
this is
probably
one of my favorite ways to pull focus
it's so good that sometimes i don't even
need to do my job uh we just used
autofocus and basically i could just sit
here hang back
eat an orange or something and just let
the camera do pretty much all the work
for me
thanks dji for taking my job
i'm gonna be getting this crazy single
take because this camera is meant to fly
and i'm gonna let it spread its wings
because it's about time that we showed
off these guys abilities
all right here we go boys whole thing
don't rush anything and
action
[Music]
uh
nice work guys nice that was great that
was good that's a wreck guys
[Music]
it was a lot for me to ask you after
over 10 hours in the day to do it in a
winter i really appreciate all you guys
can work he's good
he's good this was a lot of fun because
i share some of luke's attitudes about
movie sword fights it's very rare to
actually get a sword fight that lasts
where it's two characters having a
conversation with their weapons and
there's a lot of big battle scenes where
people are like you come in you swing
the sword you die it's just great to be
able to put a fight together where you
can see the story develop i think
realistic sword fights are more exciting
than than more stylized exaggerated ones
obviously there's style has its place
but i the really good realistic fights
make you sit on the edge of your seat
because you your body recognizes that
that's dangerous we tried to show that
there was actual
you know thought and danger and
decisions you know there's gravitas to
everything with a fight like this you
need you need that cinematic smoothness
you need that that feeling like an
omnipotent god looking at his creations
like i was gliding and flying all over
the place i mean there's shots i'm
getting that would require thousands and
thousands of dollars worth of like
steadicam tech and you know a crew to do
and i'm just like i'll try this like
yeah
matt basically never biffed focus
imagine that imagine having a lidar and
you just use that to pull all your focus
the ronin 4d is the kind of camera
that i wanted
since i started making youtube videos to
me that is the perfect camera
how do you reinvent the lightsaber
visually how do you make it look
different how do you make it look better
there's a lot of ways actually i've been
thinking about this for a long time
here's how i'm going to try to improve
the look of an energy sword first and
foremost the light
right they're light sabers they give off
light the look of the lightsaber that
everybody remembers kind of comes from
the prequels or it's the white core and
the colored fringe and that's kind of
how everybody does fan film lightsabers
these days because the white core
represents parts of lightsaber being so
bright they're overexposing the camera
and of course as it fringes off as it
blurs out you can actually see the color
there because exposure's low enough the
problem is when you move something
really fast the motion blur basically
lowers the exposure and that white core
should turn into the color of the
lightsaber but that's not how they do
the lightsaber effects they just draw a
big white fan so i want to approach
lightsabers realistically with how they
would physically work on camera so in
star wars the lightsabers are either cut
out by hand frame by frame or they're
tracking a cgi blade onto the lightsaber
frame by frame that's very very time
consuming and you also end up with
something that looks artificial because
you're adding something artificial to
the shot i needed to come up with a
system that was not only faster than the
way that they do it for the star wars
films but i wanted a system that more
accurately reflected what would
physically happen if you're filming
somebody's swing a laser sword so here's
what i came up with so as you can see
here in the original footage this is the
raw shot here the lightsaber is actually
pretty bright they give off a lot of
light on their own and the yellow
lightsaber is also very saturated and
has a lot of color so through a
combination of chroma keying where i
isolate certain colors and luma keying
where i isolate certain brightness i'm
able to create a mask here that just
gives me the lightsabers as you can see
here by the two white sticks so now i
can pass that in to another section that
will take the bright parts of the image
and raise them even more and since it's
isolated just where the lightsabers are
it's basically just raising the
brightness of the lightsabers so now
i've upped the brightness of just
lightsabers i can apply a glow filter to
the entire image and because the
lightsabers themselves are the only
things in the image that have this
brightness they're the only things that
glow in addition i can also add
something called lens reflection boom
so this mimics how light passes through
the different glass of the lens and
reflects within there and then gets
filmed so by combining the aperture
diffraction which gives me the glow and
the lens reflections i end up with a
realistic looking lightsaber glow that
glow as if it was filmed on set being
that bright then as the sabers move and
they're swung around and they changed
kind of their hue and brightness so too
does the glow shift and so too did the
reflection shift very realistic and it
changes the look from what you're
conveniently seeing in a star wars film
while still maintaining the identifiable
look of an energy sword and it's much
much faster than tracing it all by hand
thing number two that i'm going to do
differently visually i need to come up
with a way to deliver the vibe of this
energy source what makes it dangerous so
rather than just having them hum and
flicker i want them to feel like they're
jets of fire weird like hybrid light and
fire put together and matt took it and
ran with it and did something pretty
incredible we went in a dark room with a
black uh little piece of foam and a
glass of water and a flashlight all the
light refractions that you get from
shooting that light through the water
gives you a stack of assets and then
just layering those on top of each other
additively adding some extra like jet
flame elements in here gives you this
see this is like an older star wars
movie the light that's shining on his
hand through the lightsaber there like
that wouldn't be there yeah just having
that practical light here just
immerses you in the effect i'm so happy
with it honestly it turned out really
well number three if you're doing a
fight scene it's crucial that people
follow what's happening in the fight
scene where the strikes are going how
they're being blocked i want to enhance
it and highlight it and make sure that
you can distinctly see what is going on
we have an idea here and that is to
create sparks we leaned somewhat on like
pre-made stock assets which are great
but given how dynamic this is and seeing
how we see the floor and and everything
moves in such a realistic way we wanted
to try and generate our own sparks so
what i put together i went ahead and
built a little spark emitter which
basically can be aimed in any direction
at any time and will spit out a little
uh celebration of sparks basically all i
have to do then is load in a still
reference image of the background and
line up that little spitter and we can
spit sparks on literally any shot we
want to and it's nice to have the
reflections of those sparks and the
illumination that those sparks create
actually in the scene because it grounds
it so much more it gives a lot of
directionality to the strikes it really
helps lead the eye
it helps you understand what's actually
going on in the chaos of this fight
all right so we changed up the
choreography created a new visual
language for the lightsabers tried new
sound design it's all done
here's the finished piece please tell us
what you think
[Music]
graduation day
huh
the student must experience a real fight
before they're ready
what makes it a real fight
you have to kill your opponent
[Music]
you need two things to win a sword fight
perfect distance at the right time
right now the teacher controls both
if the student doesn't start forcing
opportunities he's going to get cut he's
nervous
he's scared
your body doesn't want to cooperate when
you're scared
oh jesus
oh god
oh my god see this school is [ __ ] up
this school
breeds the best sword fighters in the
world
you want to know why
[Music]
so
[Applause]
this company's fear
now he just needs to temper his attitude
let's see if he wants it
[Music]
who are you
this is my school
want to join
[Music]
so after basically two years of not
shooting anything narrative because of
covid it's been nice to get out there
and actually make some cinema again
thanks to all of you for watching it
thanks to dji for
basically making a camera that's
equivalent to what i asked for my
perfect camera video from 2018 it was
really fun shooting this video on it
thanks to luke
kendall and steve for your awesome
choreo jordan and porya for your awesome
acting
kevin for awesome sound design jordan
matt for awesome vfx i can keep going
you're probably already leaving the
video by now so anyways bye bye consider
subscribing leave a comment or something
see ya